combien de temps a duré la guerre de
Cent Ans
on va faire une triple interview le
principe est très simple le principe de
la street interview c'est si vous pouvez
pas répondre vous retirez un vêtement
[Musique]
bien
alors je m'adresse à toutes les trois
les filles ok
quel âge avez-vous vous
obligez de répondre
quel âge avez-vous
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
donc Bamba ne veut pas dire son âge vous
veulent bien à quel âge avez-vous oui 29
ans 29 ans
bien alors on continue à toutes les
trois les filles bon bah aussi quand
avez-vous fait l'amour pour la dernière
fois
tu devrais t'en souvenir
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
S
[Applaudissements]
et vous psycho
je me souviens toujours pas genre
ça marche qu'une fois non je viens de
sauver la vie une fois mais ça fait un
peu longtemps alors
c'est quoi une botte
quelle drogue utiliser
au pluriel
non moi c'est très simple moi c'est tout
ce qui pousse oui le café le thé le café
le raisin quelques fleurs quelquefois
du gazon
valga à quelle drogue utiliser vous le
chocolat a bien joué elle est maligne
cette nouvelle gamme et vous psycho
d'accord
ça fait deux bottes ça sérieuse
public
il y a un moment si je sens entre vous
un truc bien tu vas commencer à être
maître et elle est en train de devenir
soumise ça va se terminer avec une boule
dans la bouche un chien qui passe
alors là c'est la première qui répond là
je peux pas demander à tour de rôle quel
est le président de Géorgie qui a
démissionné la semaine dernière c'est
qui bravo
mon bas tu n'es pas que belle
[Musique]
combien de temps a duré la guerre de
Cent Ans
tu nous prends tous pour des lémuriens
c'est pour ça ah oui moi je propose
qu'on joue en équipe là bas
combien de temps a duré la guerre de
Cent Ans
je crois que ça a duré
115 ans
[Musique]
en plus ça fait 1h30 que j'y dis rien et
la seule truc qui soit poil et voilà et
là maintenant la dernière question
j'espère que quelqu'un va enlever le
haut parce que vraiment j'y tiens
beaucoup toi tu es à poils en plus je
suis gaulé de la mort
[Rires]
bon bah les filles il a quel est votre
numéro de portable
alors là vous allez pas me croire parce
que depuis le début vous me croyez pas
je n'ai plus de portable elle a perdu
pendant la guerre de Cent Ans
[Musique]
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
innarditube abonnez-vous et mettez un
pouce bleu